[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faut sillonner le territoire pour
vraiment prendre la mesure de son
immensité deux fois plus vaste que la
belgique l'abitibi-témiscamingue compte
seulement 148 mais l'habitant une
population très dispersé pour qui
l'accès aux soins de santé diminue
premier exemple au sud en raison du
manque d'infirmières l'urgence de
témiscamingue est fermé chaque nuit
depuis juin
on était au bout de la route donc on est
négligée
ici la pénurie de personnel frappe
encore plus durement qu'ailleurs au
québec l'an passé l'hôpital de ville
marie a même envoyé des femmes accoucher
à rouyn noranda même les patients qui
souffrent du cancer et coassin chemin
quoi et pouvant atteindre d'examen de
test the terror qui se font à
l'extérieur
jean claude braud a dû faire des
milliers de kilomètres pour des examens
à gatineau une chirurgie à rouyn noranda
n'est pas en forme à la limite 5 5
mais campé par enfant a pas mal partout
c'est autre chose une des causes du
problème c'est le manque
d'omnipraticiens pendant que leur nombre
augmenter globalement au québec il a
baissé de 223 à
198 depuis 2015 en abitibi témiscamingue
la courbe santé de ville marie est le
reflet de la tendance il y avait dix
médecins en 2008 il n'en reste que 5
dans les cliniques on a 12 m2 médecin
normalement faire une prise en charge
adéquate pour travailler avec les
horaires d'aujourd'hui on aurait besoin
d'une douzaine de clubs français à ville
marie les médecins estiment qu'il
devrait être deux fois plus nombreux
qu'au bout d'un moment on a une trop
grosse charge de travail
on nous pousse à combler les systèmes de
gamme on nous pousse à faire de la prise
en charge à faire tout ça est un moment
donné on a envie d'aller aussi bien une
lourde pression qui est loin les jeunes
mères
des enfants ici plusieurs critiques la
centralisation de 2015 qui a créé seul
établissement ou sus pour toute la
région des tests sont en jeu quand je
les appelle le monstre mais ils sont
déconnectés de la réalité souvent on
arrive avec des problèmes ou des
solutions qui seraient la gare
nous reprenons la route vers le nord ici
aussi la frustration est là mais autour
de rouyn noranda cinq points de services
ruraux comme celui de montbéliard ont
été fermés
celui de cléricy est fermé lui aussi les
citoyens sont furieux vous vous sentez
comme un cominois carrière
vous allez prendre qu est ce qu on vous
donne
le 6 d'abitibi-témiscamingue évalue
qu'il manque déjà 300 infirmières l'une
des solutions à ce problème est de
recruter à l'international on a de la
difficulté beaucoup au niveau de la
rétention leurs fonds vers
l'international sur la dernière cohorte
de
la sent aussi victimes de la pénurie la
moitié des 40 lits de l'hôpital sont
fermés à cause du manque d'infirmières
mais ici la communauté s'est retroussé
les manches et a lancé une grande
séduction c'est la première fois que des
infirmières d'immigration vont arriver
ils vont avoir des
dix huit infirmières du maghreb
arriveront en octobre et leur accueil et
planifiée de a à z et david on a même
trouvé un logement pour chacune des
recrutés le logement que vous avez
carrément réservé pour une des familles
les 75 et demi qu'on a préparé pour nous
infirmiers les meublés ont beau mettre
la vaisselle on mettre la lutte est
hélas assez donné les moyens financiers
pour réussir on a ramassé au total 195
millions et ça va servir à donner
quand on travaille aussi à rapatrier des
jeunes originaires de la région comme
ariane beaudet et olivia bord
en octobre à saran verra sa propre
délégation en france pour recruter les
communautés qui vont s'en tirer mieux
c'est celle qui vont se serrer les
coudes qui vont s'assurer de ne pas
travailler en équipe pour
renverser cette tendance nous
une tendance qui frappe durement
certains patients comme jean-claude même
s'il vit avec un cancer il n'a même pas
de médecin de famille j'appelle info
santé on me dit par an par médecin de
famille j'en ai pop aliens clinique sans
rendez vous il y en a pas non plus
il souhaite que les professionnels
prennent conscience des besoins de la
région est-ce que c'est l'association
des machins qui
s'est passé c'est une des individus qui
sont là sont importants si c'est sûr de
nous voir on a développé ici david
gêne-t-il et radio canada à ville marie
au témiscamingue
[Musique]